been a lot of incoming shelling here in
kevison City this morning this just one
strike strike we understand that this
building is a medical facility involved
in forensic analysis at least two Medics
we've been told were injured in this
attack we understand another civilian
also a woman telling us that her
daughter has been taken to hospital very
distraught indeed
obviously yeah
foreign
and as I say this is just one of a
number of sites in residential areas
that have been hit today as this effort
to deal with obviously the crisis as a
result of the destruction of the noble
kakov kadam continues in this region we
understand that the evacuations now have
pretty much been completed but there is
a mammoth Aid distribution effort
ongoing across this region